كانت قبل هي يعني عم تحكي وكل شيء تمام هي
قبل الحادث يعني كانت من الاوائل على
المدرسه لكن بعد ما صار هذا الحادث انه
الزلزال وهيك معاها اثر جسمها كتير هلا
الحركه صعبه شوي عليها مرحبا
[موسيقى]
اعملي لي الاكله
الحمد لله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
شوي صعبه بس انه من ناحيه النطق اكثر شيء
بدها علاج فيزيائي على المدى الطويل
[موسيقى]
على المدرسه لكن بعد ما صار هذا الحادث
نور الزلزال وهيك معاها اثر جسمها كتير
هلا الحركه صعبه شوي علي عندك
وكان نزيف الحمد لله وقف الحمد لله كامل
التهاب صدره مكسوره
لا الحمد لله الاهالي دغري سافوها الاهالي
يعني يمكن شغل الساعه وكانوا مسافرينة بس
لاجيت لهون كان حالي ميؤوس منها الحمد لله
من فضل الله الله نجاها لا الحمد لله
الحمد لله بفضل الله الحمد لله
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
بدك ترجع المدرسه ان شاء الله بترجعي
وبترجعي من الاوائل ما هيك
غمزي له لعمو جميل